Salut ! Alors je sais on est en aout et j'avais dit qu'il n'y aurait pas de vidéo en aout.
Mais il s'est passé quelque chose qui mérite que je fasse une vidéo.
Nous avons franchi le cap des 600 000 personnes qui suivent la chaîne !
C'est-à-dire qu'il y a un an tout pile quasiment jour pour jour qu'on était à peine 60 000 et là on est 600 000.
Merci ! Bravo ! Vous êtes comme ça !
Alors je ne sais pas si vous vous en souvenez, mais pour les 200 000 abonnés j'avais créé un truc
pour que vous ayez tous un cadeau, mais vraiment, tous, les 200 000, un cadeau physique.
Vous aviez été 17 000 à envoyer un courrier pour le recevoir.
Alors pour les 600 000 je vous propose quelque chose dans le style.
Mais plus facilement accessible.
C'est-à-dire je viens de créer quelque chose comme vous avez du le voir dans le titre.
Qui va être accessible aux 600 000 personnes, si vous le voulez.
C'est un cadeau !
Alors il s'agit d'un tour de magie que vous pouvez faire passer pour du mentalisme.
Pourquoi j'ai pris cette option là pour vous offrir quelque chose ?!
Ben, écoutez, c'est très simple moi je vais vous le dire tout de suite. [imitation Sarkozy]
C'est parce que là je voulais vous offrir quelque chose d'inratable.
C'est-à-dire qu'il n'y a pas besoin d'un entrainement, il n'y a pas d'erreur possible.
Ca fonctionnera à tous les coups.
Et avant de vous le présenter, sachez que ça va être accessible d'une manière virtuelle pour vous.
Comme ça, ça tout le monde peut l'avoir.
Mais j'ai aussi créé une version collector qui se trouve dans cette petite enveloppe juste ici.
Le thème que vous allez utiliser pour en parler à vos spectateurs ou à vos amis quand vous allez leur faire l'effet,
ça va être sur le thème de la fréquence des longueurs d'ondes des couleurs.
Oui, c'est un petit peu compliqué !
Ainsi que la fréquence des neurones qu'on peut mesurer dans le cerveau lorsqu'il identifie une forme simple.
Avec ça deux effets possibles.
Non pas un, non pas trois, mais deux madame !
L'un où vous allez prédire une fréquence,
qui va être librement choisie et de manière aléatoire par un spectateur.
Et l'autre om vous allez faire un calcul mental ultra rapide.
Mais plus rapide, tu meurs !
Dans l'enveloppe que vous allez recevoir, je vous explique à la fin comment vous allez faire pour la recevoir...
Vous allez trouver ces 5 petits cartons !
Comme ceci.
Quand je vous dis que c'est du collector, c'est une impression de qualité, sur un papier avec un coeur de couleur.
Pour les 600 000 à avoir rejoint la chaîne, je ne me fous pas de vous !
Et de l'autre côté à chaque fois, vous allez avoir les symboles: cercle, croix, vague, carré, étoile.
Qui se reproduisent sur chacun des cartons.
Et à chaque fois avec une couleur différente, et en face de chaque symbole il y a toujours une longueur en Hertz et toujours d'une valeur différente également pour chacun des symboles.
Il n'y a pas deux fois la même valeur dans les 5 cartons.
Effet numéro 1: Vous demandez à un des spectateurs de le mélanger sans que vous puissiez voir vous à l'avance ce qu'il fait.
Et pendant ce temps là, vous écrivez une petite prédiction sur un bout de papier.
Pendant que vous écrivez votre prédiction sur votre bout de papier, vous demandez également à un spectateur qu'il sorte soit une calctulatrice soit son téléphone portable pour le mettre en fonction calculatrice.
Vous, vous écrivez votre prédiction, là je ne regarde pas ce que je fais, et je peux vous dire que ça va être, ma prédiction va être en tout cas 197,79.
Une fois qu'il a fini de mélanger, vous ne regardez toujours pas ce qu'il fait.
Vous lui demandez de tenir tous les cartons vers lui, comme ça.
Egalisé, avec le côté identique à tout le monde vers vous.
Et vous lui demandez sur sa calculatrice d'additionner les fréquences hertziennes de la manière suivante:
Il va, sur le premier carton, noter la fréquence du cercle,
ensuite il le passe derrière,
et il va noter maintainant la fréquence de la croix,
de l'autre couleur, orange.
il le passe derrière,
il note la fréquence des vagues,
donc là dans notre exemple c'est jaune.
Puis la fréquence du carré,
et enfin il additionne la fréquence de l'étoile.
Donc vous avez bien compris, à chaque fois il doit additionner les fréquences entre elles et en descendant d'un cran à chaque fois.
Donc cercle, puis croix, puis vague, puis carré, puis étoile.
Dans l'odre qu'il veut.
Il pourrait même prendre tous les 5 devant lui et choisir un cercle, une croix, un carré, des vagues, et une étoile,
du moment en fait qu'il ne prenne pas 2 éléments venant du même carton.
Il a le droit de ne prendre qu'un seul élément par carton.
Donc je trouve que le plus simple à faire c'est comme je vous ai proposé:
de lui faire égaliser, et de lui faire prendre le premier,  puis le deuxième du deuxième, puis le troisième du troisième, puis le quatrième du quatrième, puis le cinquième du cinquième.
Il fait l'addition des 5 fréquences hertziennes, il va trouver là en locurrence si vous regardez ce que je viens de faire dans la vidéo,
197,79 !
C'est une astuce mathématique qui se cache à l'intérieur de ce principe qui vous fera tomber toujours sur ce résultat là, quoi qu'il arrive.
Si vous expliquez bien ce que la personne en face doit faire, que vous le faites convenablement,
c'est-à-dire, elle choisie à chaque fois les 5 symboles, mais ça doit être les 5 symboles différents ET de 5 couleurs différentes,
si on fait l'addition à chaque fois des sommes en Hertz mises dessus, on obtient, toujours: 197,79 !
Sur le dos des cartons qui sont tous identiques, vous voyez que j'ai mis mon nom, j'ai mis que c'est le cadeau pour les 600k,
le test des 600k,
et juste en dessus vous avez le numéro de test.
Je ne vais pas réussir à faire le point dessus mais c'est le test 192719.
C'est un petit moyen mnémotechnique pour vous rappeler du résultat.
Si jamais vous ne l'avez pas fait depuis longtemps ou vous avez un doute, ça se lit: un 9, donc ça c'est le début,
deux 7, donc en fait il faut le comprendre 7 7,
il y a deux 7,
et un 9.
Donc juste 9.
Parce qu'il y a un seul 9.
Donc ça fait un 9, deux 7 qui veut dire "7 7", un 9, qui veut dire "9".
Soit: 197,79.
Bah oui j'ai essayé de pensé à tout quand même !
La deuxième possibilité de présentation qui est juste l'un des possiblités.
Je suis persuadé que vous êtes capable d'en trouver une encore plus pertinente qui vous conviendrait encore mieux.
C'est que, au lieu de prédire, vous diposez les 5 cartons comme ça devant quelqu'un.
Vous demandez à une deuxième personne de sortir son téléphone en mode calculatrice.
On va dire personne n°2.
Et vous dema,dez à la personne n°1, de choisir dans sa tête pour commencer, bref vous lui expliquez le principe et vous justifiez ça comme vous voulez.
C'est votre job !
Vous lui demandez ensuite de dire les chiffres en hertz le plus rapidement possible.
Et le job du spectateur n°2 c'est de taper les chiffres et les nombres en même temps que dit le spectateur n°1, pour créer l'addition de tout ça.
Alors je vais vous le dire, ça va se passer tellement vite qu'il va perdre pied, il ne va pas réussir à la faire le spectateur n°2.
Sauf que vous, dès que le spectateur n°1 a terminé de prononcer ça, donc il va speeder,
vous anoncez tout de suite: "Heu... 197,79 !!!"
Et vous aurez raison, et là vous allez pouvoir prendre le temps avec le spectateur 1 et 2, de vérifier et de refaire l'addition calmement avec la calculatrice du spectateur n°2 !
Ce qui explique donc que vous avez calculé très très rapidement.
Parce que là sur deux jours, j'ai essayé ça sur un petit peu tout le monde, je peux vous dire que cette version là est très drôle aussi.
Quand la personne commence à dire [rapidement]: "40,92+62,73+13,02+24,32+56,80"
et que toi tu donne le résultat tout de suite, tu es un killer !
Alors pour avoir ce cadeau là que je vous fais, pour vous remercier parce que c'est bien normal,
vous avez un lien dans la description, pour télécharger tous les fichiers PDF, et aussi un fichier qui reprend un petit peu les explications, un résumé de tout ce que je viens de vous dire.
Ce sera quand même plus simple.
Mais quoi qu'il arrive cette vidéo elle restera et vous pouvez regarder si vous voulez m'entendre expliquer.
Maintenant pour avoir l'une des versions collectors, alors j'en ai fait 30 exemplaires, comme je vous ai dit au début de la vidéo,
les 30 exemplaires seront numérotés,
celui-ci étant l'exemplaire numéro 0.
Donc je vais vous en faire gagner 30, pour ça c'est extrêmement simple, je vais faire un tirage au sort dans les commentaires de cette vidéo,
je n'ai jamais fait ça, et pour le faire dans les commentaires vous devez juste mettre comment vous avez découvert ma chaîne,
soit depuis combien de temps, soit en quelles circonstances, si vous vous en souvenez et si vous ne vous en souvenez pas vous dites je ne m'en souviens plus,
et à la fin de votre commentaire vous mettez le "#MENTALO"
M-E-N-T-A-L-O
En parallèle, et c'est très important parce qu'après je ne serais pas capable de vous contacter.
Je ne sais pas comment on pourrait faire, donc en parallèle une fois que vous avez fait ça,
vous cliquez dans le lien de la description,
ça vous envoie vers un formulaire,
et dans le formulaire vous mettez votre adresse mail, comme ça si vous gagnez je vous contacte avec ça, et votre pseudo sur YouTube, extrêmement important !
Puisque le tirage au sort va se passer de la manière suivante:
le 31 aout, date du tirage au sort, je fais donc le tirage au sort grâce au fichier que ça aura généré le formulaire,
paf, je séléctionne les 30 personnes, je regarde les pseudos, je vais chercher dans les commentaires si le pseudo a bien laissé le commentaire avec le hashtag.
Je lui envoie un mail, c'est peut-être toi, et je te demande ton adresse pour t'envoyer directement l'enveloppe.
Voilà ! Tirage au sort 31 aout.
Je pense même que je le ferai en Live sur Instagram.
Mais en fait c'est une bonne idée ça... Je ferai ça en Live le 31 aout sur Instagram.
Directement en direct.
Comme ça vous pouvez me rajouter sur Insta si vous ne le faites pas, et voir le tirage au sort directement sans coupure, sans rien, comme ça vous voyez tout !
Petit bonus des famillles, on n'a jamais fait ça sur la chaîne mais je pense que pour fêter les 600 000 ce serait drôle de le faire.
Si la vidéo dépasse... j'en sais rien moi... les...[réfléchi]
...
Oui j'en sais rien en fait...
Comme il y a 30 tours, on va dire 30 000 likes.
Si elle dépasse les 30 000 likes j'en ferai gagner 30 de plus.
C'est-à-dire qu'au lieu de tirer 30 personnes j'en tirerai 60.
Et les tours seront numérotés de 1 à 60.
Voilà c'était ça la surprise pour fêter les 600 000 personnes sur la chaîne.
J'espère que ça vous plaira !
Que vous soyez tiré au sort ou pas, n'hésitez pas à télécharger le fichier, de toute manière il est là pour ça,
il est accessible à tout le monde.
Comme ça je suis sûr et certain que les 600 000 que vous êtes, vous pouvez le télécharger et le faire.
N'hésitez pas à le pratiquer, ne faites pas un biais cognitif négatif par le fait que vous connaissiez maintenant comment ça fonctionne.
Même si je suis persuadé que spontanément vous ayez compris mathématiquement comment ça marche, mais ce n'est pas grave ça on s'en fiche.
L'important c'est que ça fonctionne.
Mais amusez vous a le tester à le faire, je vous assure que c'est très agréable à faire et que les réactions du spectateur en face ou des personnes en face sont assez rigolotes !
Je retourne à la préparation des vidéos pour la rentrée,
sachez que ça avance bien et qu'on va bien se marrer à partir du premier septembre, donc rendez-vous le premier septembre !
A 15H sur la chaîne.
Sauf si d'ici là on passe les 700 000...
Mais là mon pote faut pas rêver ! [rires]
Donc rendez-vous le 1er septembre à 15H ! Merci pour tout !
Merci du fond du coeur !
Merci !
Ciao !
Alors si ce n'est pas encore fait tu peux aussi t'abonner à la chaîne simplement en cliquant sur le petit rond que tu vois, voilà juste ici.
C'est ce petit rond là.
Ca marche depuis la tablette, le téléphone, c'est extrêmement partique !
Il n'y a plus de raison d'attendre.
Allez-y ! Abonnez-vous !
C'est cool !